We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David p.
This voicemail is sort of hard to understand,
but it's a question I've never gotten before
and it's kind of an interesting one.
So let's take a listen and figure it out.
I'm daisy, I've lady in front of the studio
audience now.
I don't want to hold you.
I was just wondering, have you ever considered
the life as I see the risk and a gamble, you
know [inaudible] on the seas.
Drink rum.
No, no one's going to come next.
It's a really good life and I just think it
might take a day away from studios and don't
show, take a bit of it.
No part to me, I guess.
See when I see you Debbie, have a good life.
Tell Kim earth I wish her players and tell
everyone your family that I wished in pleasures
and ours last night.
Okay.
Um, I have not considered a life on the high
seas.
First of all to get to what are the, I don't
know where the high seas start and you're
no longer just like slightly off shore, but
I think that I would need more than a day
to make it to the high seas and then back,
although maybe I'm wrong about that.
I tend to get, um, uh, seasick.
So no boat related stuff is not great for
me.
The last time I was on a boat, it actually
was, was fine.
Uh, I was on a friend's yacht down in the
Florida area and it was not, uh, not bumpies,
not even the right word.
It was not her is turbulent the right word.
It wasn't very wavy, I guess is what I'm saying.
And I felt fine fortunately, but even like
once I went to, um, the, uh, the Yucatan and
took a short boat ride from mainland Mexico
out to one of the islands, I think it was
about 30, 35 minutes.
And the swaying back and forth really was
not, uh, making, making me feel too well.
So I have never been on like a long cruise
or anything because it's a, it's not for me.
I would consider doing it if I knew.
Oh, actually no, the last time I'm so stupid,
the last time I was on a boat was with producer
Louis on a huge cruise ship that was repurposed
as a ferry between Helsinki, Finland and Tallinn
Estonia.
No, 10, nine, 10 months ago I did that.
And it was such a huge boat on such a calm
stretch of water that I felt completely fine.
Although I did take my Dramamine just to be
sure.
Um, but anyway, that, that's basically my
water related experience and I'm not, uh,
going to be a merchant marine anytime soon
or, or any of those things.
And uh, that, that's basically it.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
Uh, we will talk about a Texas, the Texas
governor signing a state ban, red light traffic
cameras.
We will talk about the FDA starting to think
about what to do with CBD products, including
CBD oils, which are getting more and more
popular and much, much more great bonus show
for you today.
Two ways to become a member and get access
to the bonus show.
Rather, two ways to access the bonus show.
Number one, become a member@joinpacman.com
regular prices I think are very reasonable.
You can use the coupon code.
This is 2020 to save 40%.
Option number two, make a patrion pledge at
patrion.com/david Pakman show, both give you
instant access to the bonus show.
If you were a bonus show viewer, you would
have known a day early
about my upcoming appearance on the Joe Rogan
experience, which I announced publicly today.
I announced yesterday on the bones show.
Um, so become a member, become a paid for
it, and I will speak to you then